hey guys what's up I'm Kate quickly
you're watching and listening to date
fails I am so excited for today I have a
new person on today well he's not really
new you guys know him he's my bestie
he's been here many times and he is
going to be a frequent co-host of mine
now which I'm very excited about Eric
Myers comedy what's up besties Kate
watches be honest and tell his people
were dating I thought that was a date
but I didn't pay so it's not a date I
always pay on my days I don't think
that's true you know that it's true
always pay for men like the last time a
guy paid for me on a date let me think
actually I did go on a date this week
where the guy paid by once yes Holy
Smoke but he took me to carry him
Cantina
which is buy one get one everything so
at least he paid at least he paid he did
but basically he paid for his stuff and
then my portion was free I wanted get
one free well he didn't take me to like
the sizzler and say you're his daughter
and I eat you on the kids menu again I
love this is our I would love for a guy
to take me on a date this is do me go
this is I mean that horrible fight the
sizzler because I was embarrassed to
take a pic I can't run around bikini at
the sizzler i me to take a picture of
her in the buffet line and I was too
embarrassed I'm like they're gonna kick
us out they're gonna get mad I wait
outside 45 minutes later she comes out
and she has pictured her sitting with
the waitstaff and they're like
high-fiving her and that we got in a
fight is because Eric promised if I
drove him to the sizzler which was 40
minutes away from where we were staying
that he would get me a funny photo of me
in the sizzler in a bikini in line with
the old people and my tray and then when
we got there he chickened out and was
like I'm not doing this it's too
embarrassing people are gonna hate us
and he like ran out you just ran out and
left me alone in the sizzler in a bikini
I scared people kids and families I was
like I can't do this
even doing the hard part exactly all you
had to do is say and you didn't even
have to be like I told him I go you can
stand way over there like a paparazzi
and just shoot me from far away it'll be
fine no one will even notice it is the
hard part because I'm embarrassed and
cake doesn't care
wait can I tell you the best part that
he's embarrassed and he thinks anyone is
gonna notice him
when I met says learn in a bikini anyway
enough of us I want to introduce our
guests can we introduce the guests yes
please alright well first of all I'm
very excited to have you here we just
met we're new friends but I've heard
wonderful things about you yeah I've
heard that you're amazing you're a New
York Times bestselling author which i
think is I can't imagine writing a book
like I can't imagine having the
discipline to finish a book I write like
post-it notes and stick them all over
yes so I can't imagine reading a book on
the town I go my ass also a podcast that
we want to talk about called you've got
issues
ladies and gentlemen Anna David thank
you so fun to be here enjoy being your
new friend
I'm not your bestie but I would have
taken the picture of you at sizzler just
to be clear cease not a competition
thank you
you could have been in it by the way
with me and I don't like so I have two
podcasts i have one called afterparty
pod that's been around for a few years
and now i just launched a new one called
you've got issues with Hannah David so
like the double meaning like you could
have issues with me but why would you
you so I talked to guests about their
pettiest issues and then we try to get
to what's underneath it and it always
works in like five minutes and they're
crying not always crying
but no it's I'm afraid I'm gonna start
crying on this podcast now I'm afraid
you're gonna happen hours I've got
powers to make people cry really no so
do you mean like if people are really
irritated in the line at Starbucks is
such a long line it really means that
they're dead and give them enough hogs
like it breaks down okay I had one this
week where a guy talked about how he
hates it when people wear pajamas on
planes which I've actually never really
seen I think I'm very like self obsessed
I'm looking at my phone on planes like
I've seen it right anyway broke down to
that when he was little his stepdad
would get mad if he was watching TV and
like he even moved the step dad would be
like you're just distracting and it got
to that and now he's angry about pyjamas
on play he's jealous of like somebody
feeling comfortable enough in his own
skin and like taking up space that he
would do something wow that's like a new
form of therapy cuz you know all that
repressed anger and you're taking it out
in bizarre ways but then the root of it
it's all it's always from like your
first five years or your first like 10
years of life 0 to 10 right working
through the rest of our lives happened
then and it all goes back to your
parents for my friend my roommate hates
mashed potatoes he's like I've never
eaten mashed potatoes in my life and
then his mum asked him one time you have
this repressed memory of her yelling at
him for like spilling mashed potatoes me
was like 4 and he like teared up it was
like so he's like 50 now in his whole
life he's like I don't know why I hate
mashed potatoes so much and then he
remembered that it was like stored away
in the subconscious that's insane to me
I mean my my mom one time made nine bean
soup that was so awful that I remember I
ate it and then I threw out for like
three days I might have had the flu you
know what I mean like I might have been
sick 9 bean soup yeah 9 bean soup so for
any of the beans that were it could have
been any of the
and every time I see beans now I cry
mashed potatoes equally disturbing but
separate
I mean if nine beans or does that he
beat any being that I see now I tear up
you know but I've forced myself because
beans are a good source of fiber and I
have trouble [ __ ] so I try to eat
beans now to keep it regular well that
was a lot about the coffee bean do you
get depressed out there
no the coffee bean is the bean that I
love that one being interesting what AG
what do you think it says we can't even
diagnose too much
how many days you have I mean what about
a green good green beans are great
because you can't see the beam you know
it's a hidden it's a different situation
yeah I'm like I I don't like beans just
to be clear you don't my mom did not
make nine bean soup but I just it's like
a consistency thing interesting it's
just great you know what's me off I'm
gonna tell you and this has nothing to
do with Danny material my parents every
Friday we get a pizza half mushroom half
pepperoni I hated mushroom that always
eat the pepperoni and the mushroom be in
the refrigerator for a week I'd like
just order all pepperoni I'm still
pissed and I cry I wonder if that's why
you're single
that is uh that's that's the only reason
I just somehow it could be related
that's little the only reason I'm not
getting laid is the pizza I don't know
what else it could be Kate yeah it was
my mind no it's it's also why you
couldn't take a picture in sizzler
because the trauma of like junk food I
don't know I'm just saying this woman is
good where's this book I am endorsing I
need to introduce our other guest
because I talked about this pizza for
another 20 min I set the alarm so anyway
we'd also go we're gonna let you go to
therapy and deal with people dude okay
so this guy that I have on today uh can
I tell how we kind of met yeah Chris Ken
I mean quiet as [ __ ] said he I've just
been set over here quite as hell and yet
the best accent of all of us isn't he so
is his dream he was totally dreamy
listen Eric's like great another reason
why I'm single so what like maybe a year
ago or so I did an episode of the
Playboy morning show you did an episode
of the Playboy morning show like a fun
day you were presenting it no I'm not
the host of that I hosted different
shows I am I'm the host of another show
called undercover on Playboy that's the
one year and so they had me on the
morning show to promote my show and then
like a few days later they have Chris on
and like they tweeted like Chris st. on
the Playboy morning show and I was like
why was I not booked on that episode
with that guy like they never booked me
with like hot guys ever they always pair
me up with like fat guys or like folk
singers like it's never who I want to be
what they teased it because I was
waiting in the greenroom waiting to go
on and then they were playing yours
things on the screen oh nice and I just
like a douche bag pulled out my phone
and I was like Twitter okay
like mutual admiration society well then
I tweeted I think I tweeted that you or
at Playboy I tweeted and I was like hey
playboy why didn't you book me and Chris
st. on the same episode and he was like
yeah why didn't you and then that's what
started our a love connection and then I
don't know we were kind of gonna get a
drink and then I was busy and then I
don't know you it's it's hard trying to
do that in this town because you meet up
with someone you're like hey you want to
get a drink on Tuesday and they're like
no I have this thing like hey you want
to get a drink on Wednesday like no I
have this thing and normally when that
happens to you the third time you try
you're like don't okay I'm gonna quit
this people are actually that's a thing
with me is that I'm so busy I've
actually sent guys so many times text
messages that say hey I'm not blowing
you off I really am this sometimes I'm
so busy I don't get on a date for like a
month would you say that this is your
date you guys I was thinking this could
be like a first date no I'm becoming it
kidding no I'm always available
let me give you a better intro than just
saying that I wanted to date you also
you are a star intro ever nine beans
taking effect all nine beans you also
had a TV show called tattoos after dark
and and you have a shop in Hollywood
right a piercing shop do you do tattoos
as well or just piercing
I don't do tattoos as well just body
piercing and then a really weird thing
called scarification which is scarring
the skin no that's um there's a silicon
ring under there with a little ball on
that looks so painful does that hurt so
for people just listening who can't oh
who can't see this Chris has in his hand
a ring it looks like a condom like when
I glanced at it I thought it was a
condom and I was like that's where he
keeps them I'm kind of not in a penis I
should clarify the flesh like under so
that's one of my ass you know and I'm
standing in line but I want my dr.
pepper tell me your so you're a
celebrity piercer I mean you're like you
have a huge fan base people I'd see his
Twitter and it's all these girls like I
just want to come to LA and like Chris
Saint pierced me like girls
ou are crazy over you how often told me
first of all what is the weirdest thing
you've ever pierced
is there anything really weird it's a
toss-up there was a there was a butthole
and which was that it was a little
curved thing with two little pink opal's
on that was super kiss the bottle but it
was in between I know your acts got a
piercing oh sorry right in between the
vagina and the bum hole oh the taste the
scrotum tape how much is a taint pairs
before how do you make up the price
that's girls scrotum yeah used to kind
of Stein that you like had you never
done it before we no no
yeah we've done them who would ask for
that that sounds so the other one was a
what they call a 7-point vaginal corset
so it was three outer labia piercings in
a ring at the top then then laced
together Jesus Christ yeah wait so then
then there's the vagina laid closed yeah
why why that was her point she came in
she was like she said I have no control
over of my vagina
can you please sew it shut that sounds
like something I should do the most
legal way we can do this like when
people did their jaws wired shut so they
won't eat like an eating disorder
situation oh my god so she people
they're busy other vaginas are so it'll
stop there's no - well yeah everybody's
doing a thing they don't have time for
sex
yeah now if your vagina sewn shut I am
so horrified by the idea of sewing shut
your vagina what happens if you suddenly
decide like you can't take it anymore
and you want to have sex can you snip it
I would say so you snip the cord I would
say so he hasn't come back give it a
snip you can do that you like baby
you're the one you're the one I didn't
create a chastity belt like you won the
key wow it's like being reborn yeah Wow
horrible she's like I can't believe I
cut my [ __ ] trench coat off my vagina
but welcome to my life guys no time for
dating but if you want your visit vagina
sewn shut I'm you guys I feel like girls
that date you do they ever get jealous
of you always piercing like girls
because you must pierce a lot of like
private areas yeah like boobs vaginas
but it's 50/50 some some girls they date
will be completely fine they're like yep
that's your job that's cool but others
will just get completely you can see it
welling up inside them after like after
a period of time and then they just
can't take it anymore and I'm like yep
this is probably I'm probably not the
guy for you then have you ever pierced
the vagina of a woman you are dating ooh
yes yes I don't know it's a you guys you
like woo but to me I'm like it's my job
there's nothing - yeah have you ever
roofed the house of someone you've dated
it's like yeah
we move to the [ __ ] that girl's house
I was gonna get a clip on all my people
yeah clip-on vagina guys get their dicks
pierced yep Oh does that feel good I'm
the girl tell me okay I'm sorry I'm
curious I kind of am cuz I'm like does
that affect you sexually if the guy has
that it can yeah yeah I mean it's
supposed I actually have no first-hand
experience but like for sure supposed to
ensure I know no I'm the one who got her
vagina so thank you for not telling them
looked like you would have that well you
go through the metal detector at the
airport they're like certain pull your
pants down types of metal don't actually
go off they don't bed those detectors
are kind of trained to not go up if you
have a plate in your leg is like sets
off a different alarm I'm gonna take
over the plane that would be a great way
to sneak something into the airport if
you stuck it in your vagina and then had
it sewn shut
I'm sure my parents I will show my
vagina shut did you go through all that
you get off the plane in Denver like
what you mean it's legal scarification
is like a tattoo but a scar yeah you you
cut the skin with a scalpel and then it
heals in that shape it's yeah it's it's
great I kind of like that I think that's
hot she's into it by accident he's like
[ __ ] this is a design I meant to do this
get a little American Psycho you're like
well that just looks great Wow
really different forms that sounds
really cool
you think that's something yeah you
should get that I would do you know what
I've got your name on your forehead I've
I've always wanted to get a tattoo but I
have commitment issues
I so wait then you thought okay so a
tattoo I can get removed but let me do
something that I though I would take a
skin graft for me now remember right now
it's got a point it's even more
committed
I admire the neck tattoo though or the
face tattoo because that is commitment
commitment I got four tattoos and all
four removed really you don't have
commitment issues and then realizing you
have commitment issues
that was my tattoos if I got a tattoo I
would just get one that said commitment
issues that would be my that would be my
yeah why did you get it removed because
I changed my mind
like did you get them when you're young
and then it is kind of okay well I think
it's like I'm sober a long time like my
podcast my first ones about or two yeah
four months two days ago
Oh program for like since I was 21
oh look and you're only 23 now yeah yeah
you know so I've been sober talks is
working and so I got someone mm good job
but so when I was sort of bottoming out
I would be like doing coke for days and
going like I'm so depressed how do I
stop I don't want to stop
I'll go get a tattoo like I don't know
what I want I'm gonna walk into some
random place so or all I'm gonna go get
a cat this is what I would make these
like permanent decisions as I go to
treatment and I have four tattoos and
two cats that's true oh my god everybody
in in rehab site hell yeah ed you got
your dad's like when you're really 15
and I was like no I got them like two
months ago
and then I just decided to get them
removed and that's a really long process
to write I found a really cheap place
which I don't recommend yeah I wanna get
mine removed you do I don't see this is
why I'm glad I haven't gotten any I
sometimes I let guys put them on me with
like permanent marker to me that's a
I'll be like if a guy's like I love
tattoos I think they're so hot I'm like
give me one like draw one just draw one
on the sharp yeah okay you guys I have
four out of five and I want to get it
removed I have some of the weirdest [ __ ]
on man I'm like I'm fine with it I think
it's okay
it suit your style is so hot on guys
though like I'm so attracted to guys
with lots of tattoos like we are we are
watching your day
basically I'm attracted to every guy
every god I think beards are so hot I
think clean shaven son I think tattoos
they're tender skin grafts no you don't
find attractive if I had nine bean soup
I was like it's rather cutting that
turns me on
running with scissors and she's just oh
so if you get a paper cut he like yeah
yes you are yeah recently not I've
recently started seeing someone I knew
it my window yeah I also be Danna [ __ ]
maybe I don't know wait did you say
she'd be down to [ __ ] no no is it I also
I would be down you know you would oh I
thought you said I'd also be that's the
accent problem no she did maybe oh yeah
is she are you you guys slippy your
Twitter so she says okay offering a
threesome up by the way but now that you
all know what Kate's offering she like a
sexual gummy bed jumping around I seem
that way but I'm actually like terrified
I never hook up with guys how often do i
hook up almost never right now love a
guy one the one guy kzcover this guy and
I were talking about stomach do you see
that you with this guy in five years
that she looked at me like I asked her
if she was playing to move to [ __ ]
Venus she's like five years why do I
have to see him and I together in five
years to hook up with him right now some
people are short term plans and some
people are long-term plans my being was
why like you're like I've so many
feelings for this guy I like this guy so
much I'm like well you don't see
yourself with them in the long run yeah
well I will admit that I have a
habit of this is my bad habit which is
when I have feelings for someone that I
should not have feelings for because
there's no future there instead of
cutting it off I let it go
probably a little too long so sometimes
way too long you like to date fucked-up
people I do you're attracted to [ __ ] who
isn't I see now why you were attracted
to me this is great I'm sorry I cut
people for a living you're like yeah
that guy I could be with that guy I
would approve of Christ
I've never approved of a guy Kate's date
he hates every guy I date I have I have
forbidden her to date certain people I
mean that means he loves you you're a
proven Chris cuz you know it's off the
table me yeah if I told you about Chris
if I was like so I met this guy he has
this piercing shop and he's on this show
about tattoos and he's he's really high
and he loves to drink and he has a show
called drunk shopping we're gonna go out
what do you think what would you say I
probably a little skeptical with that
like he's a very nice guy no you are
you're very sweet
yeah I don't try to be nice I try to be
good I am very judgmental I feel I I'm
sorry but I'm just looking out for you
no you're not because you're always
right all the guys you told me not to go
out with end up being gigantic douche
bags they do yeah and and there's never
been a guy that you've liked because
I've never dated a nice guy well the guy
you were talking to on freak she never
met this guy in person and she was
talking to him on whatever Skype or
FaceTime and then this guy is loaded and
she's like he wants me to come visit him
out of state and he's like yeah just get
your plane ticket and come on out and
I'm like he's not gonna buy your plane
ticket yeah the guy makes like 10
million that's how he keeps his ten
million exact come on
I know but I find I have a friend this
just happened to where he's like yeah
the ticket she's like well the tickets
from kind of expensive and he doesn't
even take the bait he's like oh that's
too bad
well to him it's probably nothing so
he's like to us that's like five dollars
and he's like you have five dollars yeah
no that's definitely what it is but I
mean it's like if you have that much
money and you're that cheap at the
beginning how are you gonna be in the
long term I'm not like a gold digger but
if you can't spring for a plane ticket
when you've got a million
in your couch cushions like that's
that's crazy to me
true I'm just saying let's move on to
Anna I want to know what kind of guys
you're into well I wouldn't say they're
a hundred percent healthy wouldn't say
they're like out like I'm really good at
finding the ones that appear to be a
healthy and then it takes like a year to
understand just how unhealthy they are
but it isn't that everyone like I feel
like everyone shows their best side up
front
I think the let me ask you this is a
personal question you decide if you want
to answer this how long do you wait
before you sleep with someone that you
just started dating well I'm of two
minds about this I mean the truth is I
know I have slept with people right away
and it's worked out beautifully and then
I have not slept with people right away
sort of thinking like oh you know and
and it like hasn't worked out so I don't
think I don't I have never really
regretted waiting and I have regretted
sleeping with people too soon
yeah I think that there's something to
that because I feel like what happens is
if you sleep with someone right away
like if you have that intense attraction
she's like if you sleep with someone
bright oh you mean like the first date I
mean like yeah I think the whole time
not the first date but even like let's
say like I always try to wait till the
third date that's the standard idea the
third day yeah yeah so but even by the
third date if it's someone you didn't
really know you still don't really know
them much at all you've met one three
times then you hook up now if the sex is
amazing
you're doomed right because your brain
the girl brain thinks you have a feeling
yeah and there's nothing there you could
have nothing in common with this person
except like you make each other laugh
and then the sex is amazing and then our
brain starts building all these things
that we have in common does that happen
to men yeah yeah all the sudden if yeah
all of a sudden the sex is amazing
you're like this could I think this is
this love is this what I feel like you
like no it's just a really good [ __ ]
really guys feel that
- yeah III think it comes down to the
person and not the gender I know men and
women that you know women who don't do
that and men who do do that but I would
certainly not be like all men as soon as
they have good sacs are all women
because exactly yeah yeah but I mean
like I don't know many women that can
have amazing sex and not feel some
connection I've had it I had one and
tell me about it
well it didn't really even like make
sense this one ah I can't even reflect
on it he okay I meet this guy and we are
having sort of is it a date is it not a
date situation and he says to me you
know blah and my girlfriend I was like
oh okay I get it
and then later in the conversation well
my girlfriend's boyfriend and I'm like
excuse me a second yeah you meet him and
you're on a date that you're not sure if
it's a date yeah you're just hanging out
and he says the word girlfriend and I go
got it I get it
and then later in the conversation he
says well my girlfriend's boyfriend and
I'm like excuse me he's like yeah I'm in
an open relationship and so that was the
situation going in and let me do you
know it was like the only time I've ever
had a safe word I'll just say that it's
like apparently it's like I thought it
was all original for me and it's like a
common one yellow yellow yeah why is
that a safe word well it's like stop but
it's like don't stop yeah it stop is a
terrible safer stop means like do it but
I'll pretend I don't want to do it's a
complicated yeah I thought if I say stop
stop I don't I say did well I was gonna
say that I hope somebody's got a little
bit for like a time after time and that
was her thing she wanted to tell say
stop a lot but very forcefully say stop
and then I was like okay I'm done
and she was like no no no okay like and
she would like pull you and then be like
stop and I was like I just I don't think
I can do this I did about it's like a
whole thing
about because I've written about sex for
like Playboy and details and stuff like
that and I did this story on women who
have the rape fantasy and I interview
guys who like you know women who wanted
them to break in and you know and like
yeah yeah yeah a whole thing because it
sort of has to do with I think it had
you with shame and sort of like no I
just didn't I don't I never went about
that guy if you say stop he's like cool
hands away yeah I'm done and hers was
very much I had to have a conversation
with her at the start and be like when
you were saying stuff you would say that
doesn't mean and she's like okay I was
like this is the only time that ever
makes sense and he's everything and
she's like yes as like call awesome
continue that's so interesting so I
guess if you have a girl that likes to
say stop you just have to have a
conversation like hey does stop means
stop or is there another word for stop
they like to always does in any part of
society it's like opposite like go main
stop stressing you out too much she's
like stop coming over he likes oh wait
can we go back Anna to your questions
about this so this guy though he told
you he's in an open relationship because
I've had really hot guys that I've been
hanging out with that then they'll
suddenly tell me they have a girlfriend
but it's an open relationship and I just
assumed they're lying because I think
every guy that has a girlfriend says
that when he wants to cheat so when a
guy says that do you feel like you need
to find out from the girlfriend for sure
if that's true or would you be like hey
that's on him and hook up with him
anyway
okay well two things this I knew was
true because he's like my girlfriend
lives with her boyfriend like this was
an established I know it was a very
specific situation and I just knew he
was telling the truth
so weird that he still called her his
girlfriend the whole thing was weird and
the boyfriend you know the boyfriend
knew about the live-in boyfriend knew
about him anyway it was like this affair
that went on for years and it was the
greatest sex of my life and I think it
was because I always knew the situation
and I mean he didn't stay with her but I
kind of was like I don't want that
didn't work out there's a shock but I
was like I don't want to sit across the
table from him and like eat linguine
that's like not what I want from you
yeah you know he's a
wonderful guy but I will tell you one
thing like a tinder situation that I ran
across nice match with a guy and make a
date and then he says I'm an M W M which
first of all I don't know what that
means
oh I do okay and and in a polyamorous
Reed white man that's not what I thought
that was oh I thought it was I thought
that was he likes to have sex two males
one female I don't use these like weird
acronyms just say like a married yeah I
agree
although he probably doesn't because
people would just keep swiping well yeah
wait wait so he's married but his wife
doesn't care if he has a fling or he's
married and cheating behind his back but
just wants to you - no way not
interested yeah I'm not into married I
don't care if you're open I don't know
although I will say that if I was gonna
have a threesome I would want to be the
guest in someone else's relationship so
then maybe a married couple like out
yeah I don't want to be around more than
one time a guy friends who have
threesomes and now have like the same
girl like keep kind of coming back and
I'm like how do you not
I feel like eventually that would get
weird like there could be unless only
the girl contacted you and never the guy
I don't know I thought there'd be a lot
of issues right yeah but I think you and
I are a little old-fashioned like even
the idea of having a threesome for me
didn't really come into my head until
like the last couple years like that's
something I never thought about doing it
sounds intimidating I don't want to
disappoint two people you know what I
mean I gotta block two people from
Facebook you know would you have it
threesome with with your girlfriend if
she came to you and was like I really
want to have a threesome but with like
two men yeah nice oh my god next time
you're single what about you well I was
not sober for many years of my life when
in sobriety Oh
yeah no me neither okay
no wait so okay so you're single now are
you looking for a relationship yeah I
mean I'm just getting out of something
so ish you know yeah everyone's no one I
feel is truly single after 30 you're
either just ending something or starting
something new I had a guy the other day
tell me he's 100% single and when
someone says that to me I'm like that
whether you say 100% in front of single
I kind of feel like you're probably
lying
it sounds militantly single it's weird
right angry I am 97% sync my wife's
gonna die in thing what's your like you
must have had like some crazy fans and
weird dates or weird stories like what's
the weirdest date you've ever been on
um way to state or worst I went on a
date with a girl that had a fantasy
about being cooked so she wanted to she
she was she got sexually aroused by the
idea of being cooked in an oven what
yeah that was a weird one
so did you take her to like a tanning
place we were doing like a normal date
but then she would want to be dirty talk
to in the way of like you to embarrass
it say that I was again I was like this
isn't gonna work me in the face if you
have exactly like I'm gonna baste you
and put you on the skillet I've never
ever met anyone with that before or
after some people have weird well it's
kind of sad you know I used to answer
her sex dating and relationship
questions yeah it's show yeah attack the
show and heard some weird weird stuff
but I just read this book where this
girl it's called so sad today it was
like based on a popular Twitter at so
sad today why I'm promoting her book and
this is kind of dark what I'm about to
tell you but he has like she's turned on
by vomiting and the reason why is that
like her first memory of like
her mother showing her love was like
when she started to vomit because like
as kids you have all these sexual
feelings it's super confusing we live in
this repressed society and it's like
foot fetishes are often you know based
on like things that you sexualized when
you were a kid I every question on
attack of the show is about foot
fetishes I can't do fish can I say can I
say before I go anywhere that I'm not
king shaming at all like if you've got
that that's what works for you go for it
but King shame I can't do feels like a
really good name for a bank
foot fetish people are like the the most
I feel because I host the show on
Playboy TV where we explore all kinds of
sex fetishes right like actually I had
to lace up a girl's back like we did a
back corset girl you do those right yeah
maybe the same girl yes oh they
basically like put I don't know you
could explain it better than me Christ
they put metal things in the skin that
you can lace right yeah metal hoops in
the skin and then you lace through it
like it's the corset I mean it's a
fetish it's a fetish it's like part of
the medical play a fetish because even
people that look at it and they're like
okay that's not normally oh no into they
it's got that same look of a corset and
it's a naked person and it looks
attractive I don't think it even that's
I have a question about the bat unit the
bat corset if you did the back course it
would it make me look thinner like a
real corset because then I would
consider you just turn up and then
refuse to take photos of you go oh god
but no is gonna say I did an episode on
foot fetish and I had to let a guy suck
on my toes and I had to do all kinds of
like foot worship II things that people
are into like they lay in a box and you
stand on their face with your bare feet
it's called like smothering and they're
like so into it but anyway so the guy
that sucked up my toes he shows up and a
lot of my comedy shows now like whenever
I'm in Vegas I bet these guys are
obsessed and like the stinkier and
grosser your feet are the more
like it no and guys always ask me now
for like photos of my feet like I'm
telling you like if you want to make
some money and you're a girl and you
need a side income you could literally
set up a webcam business where all you
do is show your feet is all you'd have
to show and you could make a living if
you have nice feet um if you google me
you know how like the first word like it
comes up is first thing not in the David
well why wouldn't you type it in you
press based on the news yeah the next
word is why it's why how many photos
your feet did you know that there's a
website first like celebrity feet the
only reason I know is because like
somebody like tagged me and there's like
a couple Instagram posts I have where my
feet are just showing a little people
post them oh yeah I've had my feet like
up my calves there's a lot of like calf
fetishes realize why your feet are
people who set name every 30 may have
gorgeous feet I'm not even joking
gotta say though I have really pretty
usually just a minute I can't stand
fears everyone's got the limit
alright you don't post feet don't know
I've never been asked to oh man I can't
do it you've never been asked to pierce
afraid feet in fairies I should I should
let him pierce my foot okay
not on the show but Kate now Eric's late
you going down that road again cave I
gotta watch her back to his feet they're
pretty but see here's the thing you have
nice feet I don't write that's when it
gets weird when it's like not pretty
feet yeah I have fat toes and they're
too short for my bubbly people say that
they're like how do your toes hold you
up because they're too short for you
dude being a woman must be living hell I
have fat toes just a 99.9 percent of the
people in the Plantagenet my left toe is
too short
do you have body dysmorphia focus on
your feet I have body dysmorphia yes but
only in the feet yeah yeah no I mean I'm
guys are like you could be the ugliest
fattest hairy back piece of [ __ ] you
like bad as she I'm looking good today
you can
so my shave launched and it was the talk
of the town meanwhile your tanning all
this [ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ] yeah like
you don't huge difference between men
and women and I tell me if you do this
or if I'm just completely crazy okay I
have days that are sex days well I know
I'm having sex that night so I won't eat
the whole day so that I feel thinner
when i hook up she's serious she's like
I'm not eating today she counted her
coffee being coffee as her breakfast no
I do that though I know I'm gonna have
to eat so you eat early so I'm not gonna
eat like four hours before sex you know
I nothing stops me for me really yeah so
what I'm feel bloated I'm the same
because if I feel fat I don't want to
end also I've cancelled like amazing sex
just did I feel a little bloated a guy
would never I feel like well I gotta
[ __ ] you while he's eating boneless
wings and Appleby there's nothing
stopping us we're having sex I'm saying
if you have like a girl hospital it so
you would cancel if you were bloated if
I felt really disgusting yeah yeah see
so is it bloated or fat or kind of one
in the same like is it a physical thing
or how you think you it's how I feel
like if I feel like okay for instance
like I'm supposed to have sex tonight
okay but I haven't hit the gym in a few
days and I feel kind of gross so I kind
of want to cancel I have a problem
planning sex like that if somebody's
like we're gonna have sex at 8:00 I'm
not gonna be into it I need to be like
surprised with it yeah I know but you
know what the person I'm sleeping with
is really hard to schedule they're gonna
go into it but the point is like when
people are very busy sometimes you have
to schedule I find the busy when I get
really busy if I don't have sex I get
cranky really cranky like are you and
your 30s I'm sort of okay well you look
like you're 30 thank you so I'm like
ravenously horny oh my sex drive changed
like remarkably because for so much of
my sex look I didn't even know what I
liked and my you know my body just
hadn't really you know gotten to its
full potential
yeah and so like now I excited I'm not
gonna I mean I make time I make time for
it
no matter how busy I am but I have to
schedule it sometimes cuz I'm busy and
if the person I'm sleeping with I like
to sleep with people to have a lot going
on like nothing turns me off more than I
went out with a guy the other day who
works from home and he doesn't really do
much and he's like I have tons of free
time hit me up whenever you want ahead
like that's a turn-off it's like a big
turn-off yes a part of your dating it's
a part of your like sexual fantasies the
hey you want to go out Sunday no you
wanna go out Monday no and then actually
finding an hour window where you can get
it on well my favorite sex honestly is
when it's spontaneous and unexpected I
mean but it's just like that's rare for
me because I don't hook up with randoms
very often and so like when I fantasize
I always fantasize about like the first
time I hooked up with someone who was
great but it's usually like a few like I
know like the last time I had like a hot
spontaneous hookup was in Vegas like
maybe six months ago and it was so hot
and I still masturbate to that memory my
guy that I was talking about is always
my like I've dated many people since and
he has always might like he will be the
continued you go back to him always do
guys do that you always go back to
though you like more like not women
you've dated but you know poorni stuff
right so we're talking about
masturbating thinking yeah yeah like
when you masturbate what do you think
about or use um pornhub
yeah yeah no but she's saying like women
we will think about guys we've hooked up
with more I think than men where men
will use someone that they like wish
they could have Eric myself oh good lord
well this is taking a fantastic
I think I think yes it would go down
this road it always dies it's my fault
it's because I it's because of my age I
have sex on the brain all the time I've
actually never masturbated oh my god
wait who is a guy was dating that told
me there's a guy I was dating who told
me that he never masturbates that's a
lie that's some it's gotta be definitely
have met guys who are like on fasts and
like saving their cheat I mean we live
in LA like oh you're like not doing it
for a while sure I did that once for a
week please I have a friend who's a girl
who every time anyone talks about
masturbation she gets a weird face and
she's literally disgusted by the concept
was this guy he told me that it grosses
him out and that he's like turned off by
the idea of like getting himself off
he's like why would I do that
- before this is a guy that can get
plenty of women it's not a guy that's
like struggling to get laid at that
point you just like don't be a dick just
do it I wouldn't ever speak to them
again I wouldn't trust them so you think
he was lying I don't know this is it by
the way this is not thank you a lot
why would you even say that I don't know
why would you say but then my people
could say anything I got people could do
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] but then also
the same guy he would always ask me for
photos so then it's like why do you want
photos if you're not masturbating what
are you doing with them well I'm not
Sherlock Holmes but none of this is
[ __ ] Attica he's just making sure
everything on IMDB is current I'm not
gonna masturbate I don't know why you
would say that I don't even know why you
would lie about that I don't either
it's weird it is he's not masturbating
it's probably women he's planning on
killing women who have said they have
never like had an orgasm yes me too I've
met girls like that yeah you talked to
my ex when when someone says that do you
not be like in your brain you're like
right I'm getting in that like you feel
like a challenge I'm I'm
I could be the ones do this I don't want
a challenge can I say something about
that this is true this is a real story I
tell every guy that no guy has ever been
able to get me off by going down on me
so that they try so much every guy I'm
like no guy ever can get me off like
this and then they all feel like so good
about it and then they want to do it all
that to my friend
this comic from Virginia I used to tell
women he's like I don't come from
[ __ ] I never have and they look well
you'll like it was almost a chat he said
it was so that's this is like a common
trick i I got no to be able to do it I
had Katt Williams on date fails one time
and he said he said he never comes with
a girl the first time he has sex with
her on purpose because he wants her to
think about it like a mindfuck so that
she's like why didn't he come with me
and then she tries harder forever that's
crazy
do you think a little I think it's kind
of genius what about guys who fake
orgasms like wearing condoms guys do
that I've done it not wearing a condom
and I wondered how they didn't realize
that I faked it I've done that before
right I was like how do you know she's
done no the same reason women do I don't
do it I was on Madison I was on um
zoloft or prozac or paxil and I couldn't
ejaculate so after a while I don't want
them to feel bad why'd you figure it was
just it was taking a while and she
looked like she wasn't having a good
time at like it looked like I don't know
if it's all women but some women that
I've had sex with it it gets to a point
where it's painful
no because not because of a dick sight
like I'm not that's what I'm saying is
yeah it gets to a point where it just
becomes uncomfortable and I was like
okay she's she's had fun occur like a
few she's she's done her good I'm
Whateley I was like no this is not good
for her it's really sweet that you guys
faked it though because like a lot of
guys will just be like I'm good and then
the
as a woman you know that drives women
mental what because here's what what did
I do wrong
you don't want them to feel bad and it's
not their fault but you could be
mentally stressed out you could be you
couldn't it doesn't bother me when a guy
doesn't finish as long as he gets me off
a few times and he's okay with it I'm
fine with that
he doesn't finish I know it's not my
fault I know I'm not a ballet it's on
him it can be given to a be jerked off
three times that day I don't know what
he did it can be give and take those
some like sometimes you cannot finish
sometimes you can and it makes it I
think it especially in a relationship it
makes the whole thing more comfortable
and you comfortable with each other that
way I was writing it I threw yoghurt on
the face you guys are amazing
thank you guys for being here I love you
both we I thought we had to wrap it up
we're out of time Eric but luckily
you'll be back for more was I talking
about
no you're fantastic Eric at Eric Myers
comedy Kris at st. Pierre Singh and Anna
it's at Anna B David and one more time
Anna your podcast tell them where they
can find it it's called you've got
issues from Hanna David it's on iTunes
and SoundCloud and stitcher and you can
go to the issues with Anna website I
love that and Chris has a great show I
forgot to mention up top called drunk
shopping did we talk about drunk
shopping you know oh no I can do it
drunk shopping netwerk life from
meltdown comics on Sunset Boulevard
every 8:30 and every every Sunday night
at 8:30 live celebrity guest lives can
meet comedic guests they sell their [ __ ]
and they deem it drunk we also do that
as a podcast that goes on iTunes Google
Play all the things podcast with Chris
Morgan and Google Play iTunes I love
that what you guys were both great thank
you so much for being here medic and I
do I get to plug in this yeah and
of course please probably everything
court-ordered cartoon my cartoon show
that I'm trying to pitch right now you
can watch the teaser trailer on iTunes
and Funny or Die yes and you should cuz
it's really funny it's so funny with it
you're welcome guys you know you can
follow me at Kate cue funny and this has
been date Vale see you next time bye